hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play SCP containment breach now I
don't remember which way I came from
this is all strange to me let me look in
my navigator ultimate oh I'm surrounded
by dead ends but what is down these dead
ends
what is down you let me blink again with
the weird door closed eNOS what was down
you I don't I don't quite recall I don't
know what to deal with that is because
it's like instantaneously OOP blue do
doop engineer
what is this why why we're all the doors
closed anyway like that what the what
what the hell did happen there what was
all that oh is that all about what is
that what is that supposed to be
poof Goggins okay now where the hell did
I go and where the hell am i coming from
how do you remember I'm so confused I
don't remember what I was doing in the
last episode do you know
I kind of string things together after a
while
you know this scares get Kanna
ah-ha-ha-ha I know I haven't been here
yet because I haven't gotten some of
that SCP 420g
oh yes
dawned world it's Lindy ah bollocks oh
no he's gonna be here after you buddy
fu and you're slightly turned head up
come here come here come here come here
you are not going to ruin my day this
time not gonna ruin my day I'm gonna
actually try to listen to this
I'm actually gonna try to listen to this
radio bird oh hello okay that's a dead
end
this is high oh no you don't you're
gonna do thank you
hi
stop it you anomalous duck you hey Tam
item what is this oh yeah I remember
what this is I'm an idiot okay there's
another pathway down there that I could
go if I wanted to risk going down there
which I
don't hear anything but I think I've
come this way
shelter
box
Oh
and what please
okay what is this
the Omegas okay they keep losing the
target I'm guessing that's me ergo I
should probably be careful about what
I'm doing right here let's see oh is
that a bulletproof vest no way I feel
slightly encumbered how about your dick
how about that okay
woo oh how remote see you remote
detonation alpha warheads they're both
on what happens if I turn these off will
shum shenanigans happen shenanigans
okay those are both off don't know what
that means
probably bad I probably done bad right
right guys
I done bad I've done bad not bad huh my
gosh [ __ ] yeah I [ __ ] up actually I
don't know what I did
maybe I
Tessa one and get disabled Tessa what
eNOS ha stop that you computer bastard
Tessa what engaged Tessa
who's he wanted if I gone this way or am
I know it isn't you Tessa
who's your mama don't know what he's
sick oh oh I don't need to go in here
because I don't need to contain you
graddic Allari please go opening just in
case though you ever get trapped in here
you weirdo dimension okay
stop moving forward
holy crap what is that who
ah no that's oh nice 600 have our
seniors race I obviously have not
Oh God Oh God
what happens when I see his face oh good
here we go
hi
getting dark wise a king dark oh god
okay hi I'm a look at his face
okay ha huh huh huh wha wha
Oh Oh what are you doing why am I doing
this
what am i doing this
oh I should have run oh god I should
have run
how am I do it again and this time I'm
gonna run like a little baby did I get
you
I see you're fake you're so ugly you
still ugly
okay no haha here well run how let's see
what happens I'm actually very curious
to see how far he will go to kill me
maybe I could like get the mobile task
force involved look I discovered no safe
is he coming after me lying to cover
everybody
there's still freaky utila girls and
boom right after me okay I'm looking at
the [ __ ] wall you go you go to hell
and you die geez if you've ever read
that SCP that is a freaky SVP to read
it's great read though oh it's great
okay all these here are the doctor's
offices
hopefully next time I come in here
there'll be something a little more
substantial okay I'm almost out of
batteries for this thing
okay so did they finally add something
four six eight to here I'm kind of
curious where's that ah ah you [ __ ]
how are you down there oh you I had a
bulletproof vest you douche good good
good golly
how are you all I see you down there oh
well ain't you dicks I see their little
helmet visors laid you [ __ ] watch
for using my bulletproof vests aren't
give her that slightly annoying
okay so haha miss me
dick Oh what are you gonna do now
I hope 682 eats you alive I hope he
Flay's off your flesh oh no that wasn't
them it was just a shower heads oh maybe
that's them in the corner I don't know I
don't know
that's 682 holy crap ah oh that was oh
that was a guy I just saw shadow uh-oh
I'm bad at this I'm not used to seeing
you know human enemies maybe I could run
behind him uh I know you don't Rob too
fast for you wow that actually worked I
can't believe it that's so weird I gotta
close the door no I don't you'll be
right around the corner uh yeah go
there's something in my eyeball there's
something in my eye right now but I'll
tough through it for you I haven't been
in this room in a while where are there
some batteries up here hang on there
were some batteries around here
somewhere I know there's like a special
eye drop let's see if I put these eye
drops in the thingy I've heard that it
will make you not have to blink anymore
which is like ridiculously awesome and I
would love and I would love to fix that
because I seem to be blinking a lot
because there's literally is something
in my eye right now and it's quite
painful
ah crap ah crap I went the wrong way
let's try going down the other way
before they get to me where's that oh
wow Wow
oh I eyeball oh my I owe her so much ah
ah it's taking over my brain my brain so
it looked awfully familiar
ah ah ah is it a dud
her okay ha what the hell ah God don't
show me
ah hey like popped about nowhere okay
I'm digging it
oh man yeah ah good goodness gravy ah
right tear to my eye
okay so I seem to be trapped soon to be
trapped slightly huh no you don't know
you don't biznitch how do I can I just
run up and judo stop those guys next oh
man I don't know oh no no no no what am
I gonna do what am I gonna do what am I
supposed to do here he's all up in my
way if I big super sprint with my gas
mask
Oh dodge ah I feel a burning pain in my
right leg like I was after me
that guy was shooting to kill Carrie how
am I gonna get I'm trapped I got okay I
got guys all around me what this is what
this without the gas mask I thought it's
roughly dark for without okay so I don't
know what I'm gonna do
I still got something in my eye very
painful I can't go this way I can't go
back this is another guy over here I
think yeah he's there who was that look
at me like would would ya go this way
this is a guy right through that door I
mean how would they surround me maybe I
got a lead them out somehow hey you
yoohoo mister soldier man I'm batting my
eyelashes at you know activate otezla
gate oh and a ballot oh I hear talk doc
hood house hammer no you didn't detect
[ __ ] your intersect anything Oh
ah man I was tough that time all right I
don't know what the hell might do there
to there I guess I gotta be sneaky but
I'm on a time for this one so thank you
all so much for watching I'm gonna get
this thing out of my eye
yeah thank y'all for watching click the
annotation more videos that I've done
and as always I'll see you in the next
video bye bye
okay okay